皆さんは恐怖症というものをご存知でしょうか？
○○恐怖症っていうのがあるんですけども
まあ特に有名なのがたとえば
きょうしょこうふ（？）
自分が嫌になる
きょうしょこう（？）…違う
きょうしょ、違うな。元から違う
高所恐怖症ですね
高所恐怖症とか
その高いところにいると恐怖を感じる
暗所恐怖症とかあるね
暗いところだと恐怖を感じるとか
○○恐怖症っていうやつがあるんですけども
ネットでいろいろ調べてたんですけども
その恐怖症ってやつ
なんと
なんとですね
これまたびっくり
特殊な○○恐怖症っていうのがすごい色々あったんで
で、中には本当に訳わかんない恐怖症とか
えっ？って思うような恐怖症とかもあったんで
今日ちょっとそれをね
僕が見つけた恐怖症の中の
マジかこれって思ったやつを
ちょっと何個か皆さんに紹介してあげようと思います
では、行こう
まず、これはすごいと思ったのはこちらです
恐花症
花に対する恐怖症
花は脅威ではないと理解しているにもかかわらず
見たり、考えたりすることに強い不安を感じる
お花を見るだけでも恐怖を感じてしまう
というね、なかなかびっくりした恐怖症の一つでした
次
黄色恐怖症
黄色のものに恐怖を感じる
極端な場合は
黄色という言葉を聞いただけでも強い不安を感じる
コレやばいでしょ
黄色恐怖症だよ
（キャーーーーー）
あと、ピーナッツバター恐怖症
ピーナッツバターが上顎にくっつくのを恐れる恐怖症
非現実的なように思えるが
実際に存在するらしいです
ある患者はピーナッツバターがそばにあると
上顎にくっつく想像をしてしまい
異様に汗がふき出して体が震えだし
上顎がザラザラして不快になるという
（キャーーーーー）
ピーナッツバターか…
穴恐怖症
穴のぼこっとしてるのがね
気持ち悪い、恐いと感じる恐怖症でございます
（キャーーーー）
ポエム恐怖症
詩を読んだり、書いたりするとに対して
不安を覚える
相手に詩を読まれても
その意味を完全に理解できてないのではないか
という不安が増大して恐怖心につながるケースが多いです
湖恐怖症
恐ろしい生物が生息しているのではないか
吸い込まれてしまうのではないか
といった不安から湖を見ること、入ること
に対して強い恐怖を抱く
僕たぶんこれです
湖というか海の底とか
海の底もめっちゃ恐い
超深いとことかすっごい嫌いで
湖恐怖症というか海の底とかも恐怖症です
集合体恐怖症
鳥肌、苺のつぶ、魚の卵、昆虫の眼等の
密集しているものに対して
異常なまでの恐怖感や不安感や不快感などがでる症状
分からないでもないんすよね
蛙の卵のぐじゃぐじゃっていうのとかも
も～～～
無理！
アゴ恐怖症
二十顎、むくんだ顎、割れた顎などへの恐怖
「アゴでご飯をシャクってください」
「アゴでご飯をシャクっていきたいと思います」
「あっちぃ！」
（キャーーーー）
というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
様々な恐怖症があるわけなんすよ
あと、僕あれですね
おへそ恐怖症です
たぶん
実際にあるらしいんですけども
おへそを見ると何か
あんまり
なんかへそ嫌いなんすよね
へその緒切ってるんで
何か切断されてる感が
感じる
たぶん実際にね
この恐怖症っていう症状がある人しか
わかんないんでしょうね
どんだけ恐いかっていうのが
というわけで色んな恐怖症があるんですけども
皆さんももし
私はこの恐怖症だよ
っていう人がいたらコメント欄で教えてください
じゃあな
美味い
美味いじゃん